Mein Name ist Enes Ucunji und ich bin der diensthabende Arzt. Wie heißen Sie den?
Ich heiße Michael Kirchhoff.
Können Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachname bitte langsam bestabieren?
Ja, Michael schreibt sich M-I-C-H-A-E-L. Michael und der Nachname Kirchhoff.
K-I-R-C-H-H-O-F-F. Kirchhoff.
Okay, 2-H, oder?
Nein, doch Kirchhoff, 2-H.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 45 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann genau wurden Sie geboren?
Am 25. September 1980.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 Meter.
Okay, kennen Sie Ihr aktuelles Gewicht?
Ja, 87 Kilo.
Okay, danke für all diese Informationen. Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ungefähr seit einer Woche habe ich eine Erkältung und Husten.
Und jetzt seit zwei Tagen geht es mir aber viel schlechter. Ich habe auch Fieber bekommen.
Und habe Auswurf und auch jetzt Luftnot. Ich fühle mich schlapp und abgeschlagen.
Also es geht mir jetzt nicht gut.
Okay, Sie haben seit einer Woche Erkältung, oder?
Ja.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber gemessen?
Ja, ich habe gemessen. Ich habe vor zwei Stunden 38,8 gehabt.
Ach, können Sie nochmal?
38,8.
38,8, okay.
Hätten Sie schon einmal ähnliche Beschwerden?
Nein, sowas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay, gibt es einen Auslöser für diese Beschwerden?
Ich weiß es nicht. Im Anfang habe ich gedacht, ich habe nur eine Erkältung.
So, was man mal so hat. Aber das ist jetzt eben schlimmer geworden.
Okay, wenn Sie einen Auswurf haben, haben Sie bemerkt? Zum Beispiel Blut oder?
Also der Auswurf, der sieht so ein bisschen gelb und braun aus.
Ja, und braun, okay. Haben Sie etwas angenommen? Meine Medikamente?
Ich habe gestern Abend eine Tablette Paracetamol genommen, aber es hat mir nicht viel geholfen.
Okay.
Hat nicht geholfen.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Atemnot. Ist das diesem Atemnot belastungabhängig, oder?
Ja, aber ich belaste mich nicht groß. Das ist mir viel zu anstrengend.
Selbst wenn ich so in Ruhe und jetzt hier sitze, habe ich auch das Gefühl,
dass ich Atemnot habe, in Schlechtluft bekomme.
Okay, ganz schnell. Und es tut mir sehr leid, dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben.
Wie ist Ihnen Ihr Appetit?
Ja, jetzt seit einer Woche, seitdem ich die Erkältung habe und besonders in den letzten Tagen ist der Appetit nicht so gut.
Das schmeckt mir nicht so.
Okay, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit vielleicht ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Schlafen Sie gut oder wegen diesen Beschwerden?
Normalerweise schlafe ich ganz gut, aber jetzt in den letzten Tagen mit den Beschwerden und dem Husten nicht so gut.
Okay, ganz schnell. Hatte Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrochen?
Erbrochen habe ich nicht, aber etwas übel ist mir.
Gibt es Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stüllgang?
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Atemnot beim Zerpen gestiegen?
Ja, aber ich bin in den letzten Tagen wenig Treppen gestiegen, weil ich mich einfach nicht gut gefühlt habe.
Aber es strengt mich alles sehr stark an.
Okay. Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
In den letzten Nächten habe ich stärker geschwitzt, ja.
Okay. Herr Klischoff, haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, eigentlich geht es mir ganz gut. Ich fühle mich eigentlich sonst ganz wohl.
Ich nehme auch sonst gar keine Medikamente ein. Aber wie gesagt, jetzt geht es mir nicht gut.
Okay, okay, verstehe. Und haben Sie Allergen?
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Okay. Herr Klischoff, rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche. Ich rauche schon länger, seit vielleicht 20, 22 Jahren. Jeden Tag eine Schachtel.
Jeden Tag eine Schachtel, okay.
Ja.
Trinken Sie auch Alkohol?
Ja, aber wenig. Eine Flasche Bier vielleicht pro Woche.
Wie geht es Ihren Eltern? Sind Sie auch gesund oder?
Der Eltern? Also mein Vater hatte Lungenkrebs. Da ist er verstorben. Da war er 66 Jahre alt.
Und die Mutter, die ist 70 Jahre alt. Die lebt noch. Die hat etwas Zucker, Alterszucker.
Und hat vor fünf Jahren eine Gallenblasenoperation, Gallenblasenentfernung.
Ja.
Okay. Haben Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ich bin schon einmal operiert worden, ja. Als Kind, da war ich vielleicht neun Jahre alt am Blinddarm.
Und dann mit 19 Jahren hatte ich eine Knieverletzung, Meniscusoperation.
Hatte ich eine Spiegelung, Kniegelenkspiegelung. Und da wurde der Meniscus operiert.
Ist das dieser Operation komplikationlos?
Ja, das war ganz gut. Und vor zwei Jahren hatte ich einen Leistenbruch auf der linken Seite.
Und wurde am Leistenbruch operiert.
Vor zwei Jahren?
Vor zwei Jahren.
Ich verstehe. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet. Wohne mit meiner Frau und unserer Tochter zusammen. Die ist elf Jahre alt.
Was machen Sie unbegrüßlich?
Ich bin Busfahrer.
Busfahrer. Okay.
Sie haben diese Zeit eine Woche. Sie haben Erkältung. Aber in den letzten zwei Tagen haben Sie Fieber mit Gelb- und Braunauspuff.
Sie haben auch Dyspne. Und Sie haben diese Dyspne auch wenn Sie sitzen.
Was ist Dyspne?
Oh, was ist das?
Entschuldigung. Ich meine für einen Fehler. Dyspne bedeutet Atemnot.
Ach so, Atemnot. Ja, Atemnot habe ich.
Entschuldigung. Sie haben gestern Pfeilsetzermol genommen. Aber nicht so gut.
Das waren alle wichtigen Punkte, oder?
Ja.
Haben Sie noch etwas?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay. Vielen Dank.
Ich habe jetzt alle notwendigen Informationen. Haben Sie Fragen?
Ja, ich hoffe, dass Sie mir bald helfen können. Weil es geht mir nicht gut.
Okay. Keine Sorge. Wir sind hier für Sie. Und Sie sind in guten Hand.
Okay.
Ich denke, Sie haben Lungenentzündung. Und wir werden Ihnen etwas machen, um diese Diagnose zu erklären.
Und dann um diese Sicherheit zu erklären, sind noch einige Untersuchungen notwendig.
Okay.
Nachdem wir alle Ergebnisse vorliegen haben, werden wir die Diagnose bestätigen.
Okay, das können wir so machen.
Gut, dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit sich vorzubereiten für die Vorstellung gleich.
Dann denken Sie an die Fachbegriffe für Leistendruch oder Blinddarmoperation, Blasenblasen usw.
Und die Kollegen, die zugehört haben, haben vielleicht noch Ergänzungsfragen.
Oder sind alle Fragen soweit gestellt, die notwendig sind.
Man könnte noch fragen, haben Sie Schmerzen?
Ja.
Haben Sie Schmerzen? Tut es beim Atmen weh oder beim Husten?
Ja, etwas tut es weh auf der rechten Seite hinten, wenn ich Luft hole und wenn ich husten muss.
Dann ist das etwas schmerzhafter hinten am Rücken, so in Höhe des Schulterblattes.
Das ist so. Aber sonst habe ich den Schmerz nicht. Nur beim tiefen Atmen oder beim Husten.
Gut, ich lasse Sie dann jetzt etwas in Ruhe, dass Sie sich konzentrieren können.
Und einige Minuten und ich melde mich gleich wieder. Bis gleich.
Okay, guten Tag Herr Chefarzt. Ich möchte Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit? Ja, habe ich.
Okay, danke. Es handelt sich um einen 5- und 4-jährigen Patienten namens Michael Kirchhoff,
der sich heute wegen Fieber und Auswurf bei uns vorgestellt hat.
Die Beschwerden bestehen seit zwei Tagen und diesem Auswurf sei gelb und braun.
Die Beschwerden seien bei Belastungsverstärken.
Begleitend berichtete er die Spneu-Auswurf Neusea und Insomnia wegen der Auswurf und Spneu.
Okay, darf ich einmal kurz unterbrechen? Sie haben berichtet, dass Herr Kirchhoff 45 Jahre alt ist.
Sie haben gesagt, seit zwei Tagen hat er Beschwerden. Hat er nicht seit einer Woche schon Beschwerden?
Seit einer Woche ist er erkältet, hat er eine Erkältung. Seit zwei Tagen hat er...
Diese Beschwerden. Fieber und Auswurf.
Ja, sagen Sie ruhig, seit zwei Tagen bestehen febrile Temperaturen von 38,8.
Sagen Sie ruhig die Höhe des Fiebers dazu. Weil Fieber beginnt bei 38, aber es kann ja auch 39,5 sein oder so.
Sagen Sie ruhig dann wie hoch? Febrile Temperaturen von 38,8.
Man könnte noch fragen, wo haben Sie das gemessen? Oral? Oral gemessen.
Und es besteht Tussis produktiver Husten oder produktiver Tussis mit gelblich-braunem Auswurf oder Expectoranz.
Expectoranz, um bei den Fachbegriffen zu bleiben.
Und Sie haben berichtet, der Patient hat auch eine Belastungsdispneu.
Ja. Hat der Patient auch Schmerzen?
Ja, er hat auch gesagt, er hat Schmerzen und das Schmerzen ist einseitig.
Wo hat er die Schmerzen? Wissen Sie das noch?
Rechts hinten.
Ja, rechts hinten. Da würden wir sagen rechts dorsal.
Und zwar hat er gesagt, der Schmerz ist besonders bei Inspiration.
Beim Einatmen und beim Husten. Also der Schmerz ist atem- und hustenabhängig.
Der Schmerz. Okay.
Gegen diese Beschwerden nehme er gestern Porecetamol, was ja nicht helfen.
Bis auf Nachschweiß, Insomni und Nausea ergeben sich keine Auffälligkeiten.
Und die Frage nach der Vorerkrankung wurde verneint.
Operationen Appendektomie im neun Jahren, Menuskisch-OP im neunzigen Jahre und vor zwei Jahren Leistung Herni-OP.
Ja, eine Leistung Inguinal-Herni.
Oder vor zwei Jahren eine Herniotomie.
Herniotomie ist der Oberbegriff für Hernion-OP.
Herniotomie einer Inguinal-Herni links.
Und die Meniskus-Operation, können Sie sich noch erinnern?
War das eine offene Meniskus-Operation oder eine endoskopische, laproskopische?
War das eine Kniegelenk-Spiegelung?
Ja. Und?
Atroskopisch, also eine atroskopische Meniskus-Teilresektion.
Wahrscheinlich war es eine Teilresektion.
Gut, das war mit dem Alter von 19 Jahren. Sehr gut.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familienanamnese?
Ja, sein Vater, auch Bronchialkrebs, ist an Bronchialkrebs gestorben.
Ja, sagen Sie mir den Fachbegriff, medizinischen Begriff, für Bronchialkrebs.
Bronchialkrebs?
Bronchialkarzinom.
Bronchialkarzinom, ok.
Bronchialkarzinom oder Bronchialneoplasma-karzinom.
Wie alt war der Vater da, als er verstorben ist?
66.
66, also relativ jung.
Der Vater ist im Alter von 66 Jahren an einem Bronchialkarzinom verstorben.
Und die Mutter?
Die Mutter hat Diabetes-Meni-Typ 2 und Cholelytiasis und sie ist 70 Jahre alt.
Ja, aber die Mutter ist ja an dieser Cholelytiasis operiert worden.
Eine Gallenblasenentfernung hatte sie.
Ok.
Und kennen Sie den Fachbegriff für Gallenblasenentfernung?
Gallenblasenoperation?
Cholelystisch-Dectami.
Genau, Sie kennen die Fachbegriffe alle.
Sie müssen sie nur einsetzen.
Gebrauchen Sie die.
Gibt es Geschwister?
Keine Geschwister.
Sie haben nicht gefragt.
Es gibt einen Bruder, der hat hohen Blutdruck.
Den gibt es.
Und dieser Bruder hat auch noch eine hohe Harnsäure und einen Gichtanfall gehabt.
Also Hyperurichämie und Arthritis urica.
Und dann auch noch den Begriff arterielle Hypertonie als Fachbegriff.
Gut.
Gibt es sonstige Risikofaktoren bei den Patienten?
Ja, unsere Patienten haben jeden Tag eine Schachtel seit 35 Jahren.
22 Jahre.
22 habe ich gesagt.
22?
Eine Schachtel pro Tag.
Was würden Sie sagen?
Da gibt es einen Begriff.
Wenn man sagt die Dosis und die Dauer.
Denken Sie an Packages.
Also es besteht, man kann ruhig sagen, es besteht ein erheblicher Nikotinkonsum.
Erheblicher Nikotinkonsum von 22 Packages.
Das ist schon eine ganze Menge.
Ja.
Auch eine Flasche Bier pro Heer.
Das ist jetzt nicht so.
Für deutsche Verhältnisse nicht so viel.
Ist der Patient geimpft?
Ich habe nicht geimpft.
Das wurde nicht gefragt.
Wäre vielleicht bei Fieberpatienten mit Husten und so ganz gut zu fragen,
sind sie geimpft?
Der Patient würde antworten.
Normalerweise bin ich regelmäßig beim Betriebsarzt.
Auch als Busfahrer werde ich geimpft.
Weil da viele kranke Menschen in meinen Bus steigen.
Ich habe aber im letzten Herbst, habe ich weder eine Grippeimpfung gemacht,
noch eine Impfung gegen Covid.
Das hat er im letzten Herbst untervergessen.
Sonst lässt er sich immer regelmäßig impfen.
Gut, wir haben also einen Patienten, 45 Jahre alt,
der seit einer Woche eine Erkältung hat.
Sagen wir einen viralen Infekt.
Allerdings seit zwei Tagen bestehen febril Temperaturen bis 38,8.
Verbunden mit Tussis und Expektoranz.
Gelblich-bräunliches Expektoranz.
Es besteht ein inspiratorischer und Hustenschmerz rechtsdorsal.
Das berichtet der Patient.
Er fühlt sich abgeschlagen, matt.
Er hat eine Dyspnoe, sogar fast schon eine Ruhedyspnoe.
Es besteht ein Nikotin-Abusus von 22 Packages.
Er nimmt keine regelmäßigen Medikamente ein.
Der Vater ist im Alter von 66 Jahren an einem Bronchialkarzinom verstorben.
Das wären für mich die wesentlichen Punkte in dieser Anamnese.
Die ich jetzt erstmal zusammenfassen würde.
Jetzt frage ich Sie, was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Als Verdachtsdiagnose denke ich Pneumonie.
Aber als Differenzialdiagnose auch Borupschelkarzinom und M-Boli denke ich.
Als erstes Verdachtsdiagnose.
Verdacht auf Bronchiopneumonie.
Rechts Dorsal, rechtes Unterfeld, rechter Lappen.
Differenzialdiagnostisch muss man an einen Bronchialkarzinom denken.
Der Patient ist relativ jung.
Aber auch das gibt es.
Er hat einen langjährigen Nikotinkonsum.
Er hat eine sehr vereinten Vorbelastung durch den Vater.
Stimme ich Ihnen zu. Danke.
Erstmal finde ich, Sie haben das ruhig und gut gemacht.
Bestimmte Fragen sollten Sie immer stellen nach Schmerzen.
Das sollten Sie in diesem Fall auch stellen, haben Sie Schmerzen.
Wenn Sie atmen zum Beispiel.
Es gibt ja auch eine Pleuritis zum Beispiel.
Es muss schmerzhaft sein, dass das noch mal hinkommt.
Er hat etwas Schmerzen und er raucht.
Der gelblich-bräunliche Auswurf kann natürlich auch auf eine Pneumonie hinweisen.
Es muss ja nicht immer blutig sein.
Aber ein bräunlicher, brauner Auswurf kann oft ein Hinweis sein auf eine Bronchiopneumonie.
Ich würde vorsichtig sein, dem Patienten gegenüber sehr früh eine Diagnose zu stellen.
Der Patient hat schon sehr früh gesagt, was kann ich haben.
Da haben Sie sehr früh gesagt, das war klinisch schon, lag das auf der Hand.
Ich denke, Sie haben eine Lungenentzündung.
Das kann man machen.
Aber ich würde damit noch abwarten.
Sagen Sie dem Patienten, Sie haben sicherlich eine ernstzunehmende Infektion oder Entzündung in Ihren Atemwegen.
Ich würde es ein bisschen offen lassen.
Noch nicht gleich sagen Sie haben eine Lungenentzündung.
Ich würde sagen, Sie haben wahrscheinlich eine Infektion in den Atemwegen.
Das müssen wir noch genau abklären.
Dafür müssen wir Sie auch stationär aufnehmen.
Wir müssen die Lunge röntgen.
Wir müssen Laboruntersuchungen machen.
Zuallererst möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Ganz wichtig.
Ganz wichtiger Aspekt auch für die Prüfung.
Die körperliche Untersuchung ist der nächste Schritt.
Und dann entscheiden Sie, wie es weitergeht.
Bildgebung, was auch immer.
EKG, Labor und so weiter.
Aber ich würde nicht zu früh eine Diagnose gegenüber dem Patienten stellen.
Unter dem Kurs hat unsere Lehrerin gesagt, wenn die Patientin fragt, was habe ich, sie müssen sagen, was denken Sie?
Ja, was Sie denken.
Aber lassen Sie es etwas offen.
Wenn Sie sagen, Sie haben eine Infektion in den Atemwegen.
Dann haben Sie ja recht.
Dann deckt das auch die Bronchiopneumonie oder die Lungenentzündung ab.
Aber ich würde weitere Sachen noch nicht sagen.
Sie machen ja nichts falsch, wenn Sie sagen, Sie haben eine Entzündung in Ihren Atemwegen.
Das glaube ich.
Und das müssen wir genau untersuchen.
Weil das wäre natürlich, ja, manche Dinge, wenn man sie schildert als Patient,
dann ist der Arzt plötzlich ganz schnell und sagt, ja, das ist die Diagnose.
Und das kann gefährlich sein.
Dass die da wirklich noch offen sind.
Ergebnis offen.
Und dann lieber sagen, jetzt untersuche ich.
Ich auskultiere, ich perkultiere.
Und ich höre vielleicht typische Atemgeräusche, die auf eine Pneumonie hinweisen.
Aber es gibt auch Pneumonien, die hören wir nicht immer.
Wenn sie sehr tief liegen, dann können wir nicht das immer hören.
Das kommt dann das Röntgenbild vielleicht dazu.
Okay.
Das war ein bisschen schief.
Ich würde etwas vorsichtig sein.
Sie kennen viele Fachbegriffe.
Sie müssen sie aber auch einsetzen.
Denken Sie dran, Bronchalkrebs.
Versuchen Sie das dann zu sagen Bronchalkartinom.
Oder so etwas.
Aber Sie wissen die Begriffe.
Sie müssen sie wie gesagt nur transportieren.
In meinen Notizen habe ich Bronchalkartinom geschrieben.
Aber wenn ich sage.
Ja, das ist natürlich auch die Situation in der Prüfung.
Das ist klar.
Deswegen versuchen wir das ja auch zu simulieren.
Haben Sie denn einen Prüfungstermin?
Ja, ich habe 10 Tage.
Ja, habe ich ein gutes Gefühl.
Machen Sie das ganz systematisch.
Versuchen Sie die Fachbegriffe in dieser Vorbereitung zu finden.
Und nach wie vor ist meine Meinung.
Machen Sie unkomplizierte Sätze.
Die deutsche Grammatik ist gemein und riskant.
Deswegen bin ich immer dafür.
Ich lieber nicht zu lange Sätze machen.
Dann lieber stoppen und einen neuen Satz beginnen.
Das ist manchmal leichter.
Ich gehe davon aus.
Der Ramadan dauert ja noch.